y le dice adiós a los plásticos de un
solo uso desde este domingo cubiertos
vasos pitillos o envases para comida
quedarán prohibidos en la nación andina
como parte de una regulación más amplia
que busca implementar el reciclaje esta
regulación nos va a permitir reducir más
de 23 mil toneladas al año de plásticos
que son plásticos de un solo uso y por
lo tanto tiene un tremendo beneficio
para el medio ambiente
según los ambientalistas el 75 por
ciento de los residuos hallados en las
playas chilenas cada año responden a
este material de un solo uso por ello ya
en 2016 se promulgó la ley de reciclaje
y responsabilidad extendida del
productor que obliga la recolección y
reutilización de estos objetos a través
del reciclaje no es desde allí a que
está prohibido botar basura en el medio
ambiente es pero lo que falta es la
educación es la fiscalización que
realmente haya un esfuerzo importante
desde las empresas de reducir y ofrecía
alternativa la nueva normativa establece
un plazo de tres años para que los
comercios y restaurantes se adapten
mediante dispositivos de lo contrario se
enfrentan a multas de hasta un millón de
pesos chilenos algo que muchos ven con
buenos ojos si es por el bien de
del medio ambiente y estoy de acuerdo va
a ser muchísimo más caro pero tenemos
que dejarle harto algo a los bisnietos
según el banco mundial chile es el
segundo generador de residuos de américa
latina y cuenta con unas tasas de
reciclaje también bajas